all right they asked t-pain what he
thought about black history month
okay and this is what he had to say
all right actually the question is more
specific he said how should white people
celebrate black history month
any insight all right for how white
people can can properly celebrate black
history month
the right way um stop celebrating
i don't think we celebrate black history
month i think we should just have
history i don't think
they overshot it we don't want our own
[ __ ] separating us again
we want to be part of history not just
one month
so yeah that's what he said i don't
think we should celebrate black history
month this should just be history i
didn't know bane had an opinion on that
what do you think
he sounds like me with that stake line
just before like yeah
it's like [ __ ]
yeah
i think my experience in preacher's
experience a bit like especially mine i
grew up a large part of my life in
ethiopia so
even like identifying as black was a bit
of a weird thing because i just
identified as like ethiopian right my
blackness was never really something i
considered because i was everybody's
norm yeah right so it wasn't i
immigrated to north america that i
understood what like the color of my
skin meant within a greater context of a
society yeah so i think then i became
more sensitive to like okay that's why
black folks have this initiative or they
have this going on like i understand the
need for
for something like this yeah so i don't
get too mad at it i think for me it's
like i've heard this rhetoric it's
nothing you hear this like every year
pretty much
my personal take on is like if
if black folks aren't bothered at if i
can't see any negative then i'm cool
with it
i i don't know why it's like uh
i don't know why people get so up in
arms of being bothered by like you could
teach it everywhere it's like yeah you
can teach it every year and you could
also highlight it this year in this
specific month doesn't mean you have to
stop learning about it later on so
that's my thoughts on it
i mean if it can just prevent people to
be in my position while i'm in a hall
i'm in that sorry i'm in an all-white
elementary school
and then they talk about slavery
and everybody turns around i'm the only
black kid in the [ __ ] room
it's like they're not talking about
history they talking about me ah
was that what happened [ __ ] i don't
know i wasn't there yeah it's like so if
they can have a month whenever they talk
about black history or black people
always talk about
they always talk about slavery can we
talk about
other people and everything else like
the b4
like if it can prevent that from
happening not just the tragic moment
that's not just the trap it's just like
same thing with movies
oh that's a good movie what's that movie
about you know slaves
yeah well you can't exactly
yeah so if we could highlight the good
that's cool because we don't know we
don't get highlighted that's pretty much
it as a comic you know what it is corny
though every time black history month i
could be putting on all kinds of lines
it's christmas yo
if you want to make some extra money
it's kind of cool but like i'd be
getting booked on all kinds of crazy
shows i'm like but it's oh it's this
month again and the same thing my
paycheck also looked a little bit
different in the same venues
couple months before like oh we already
have a black comic book yeah you know
what's weird about that especially with
comedy is like yeah february you get all
the shine you want but i remember like i
don't know like comedy is weird because
i'll ask comedy clubs like yeah why is
the lineup like this and i've heard so
many club owners say like i don't want
to have more than one black comic on the
lineup they've just said that oh yeah
yeah
in canada
no remember what we were talking about
how about i tell you whatever we had
here they have had here as well maybe
just a couple of years back but i've
heard that i've heard that enough times
even speak to older comics they'd hear
stuff like that but i never heard that
in french comedy though because they
don't want to turn into an ethnic night
in english comedy i heard that yeah but
in french comedy i don't hear that
interesting what i heard though is like
oh yeah maybe some people don't get
accepted in um comedy school which is a
concert that they have in quebec yeah
and all this cute thing is too han
to ethnic but that's that happened to
one of my buddies but right better than
that yeah wow that's interesting they're
just so like blatantly honest about it
i mean i'm sure it's the same thing here
in the states for some life i think that
they would do it but they just wouldn't
say it like that yeah there's almost a
comfort in saying it like that because
now you know it's not your comedy that's
[ __ ] up it's their racism yeah whereas
before that they'll just be like uh
sorry you're not funny enough and now
you got to walk around going but i'm
funnier than these [ __ ] why are
they saying i'm not funny enough we
already have them yeah i think it's same
outcome but at least you know it's not
something you can control
i notice when rich people get
comfortable yeah they start talking
crates like re really yeah because like
nothing can affect if they if they
really feel like nothing can affect them
they'll just say what they're thinking
they might suggest like how many of
those nfl orders amongst other nfl
owners say the wildest things about
athletes right like you remember that
prison comment that that one nfl owner
said he said we have the inmates running
the the asylum asylum or whatever yeah
and that sounds crazy imagine what they
saying when you nod around with the
newspapers when they're just talking to
staff that's why when these nfl coaches
come out and they say oh this owner said
this or this owner said that or they
told me like yeah i don't want too many
black players i want to balance me i
believe it yeah i don't think a coach
has ever said i don't want too many
black players no no
i don't think that's ever happened in
the history of integrating i bet you
though yeah before the integration of
black players became super common
there's definitely coaches or owners who
would have liked to see a lot of white
fll players oh i mean before like it was
the winning ticket to get black folks
utah jazz is still got white people it's
like i think that there's by design here
right it's like the only team that's got
multiple white people right yeah so like
something's going on
we have we've done i've always had that
mm-hmm
at least jazzy team yeah the lead
team and
for the canadians kind of have that same
thing
where they absolutely want the coach to
speak french
[Music]
but they absolutely want the [ __ ]
coaching music he's friends he's not a
quebecer he's not they're really adamant
about that that language [ __ ] is weird
so they'd rather have a shittier coach
yes but he speaks french but he's
basically the players too right like
they want all the players we have same
thing yeah see i don't i don't respect
that yeah because you're just not
competitive enough
like let's win you should want to win
identity's more important than winning
because for them to maintain their
identity is a win i'm serious
yeah
how about this how many times you heard
someone say
i don't care
how much money my kid's partner makes i
just want them to be the same culture
for them the identity is more important
than the quality of the partner